bonjour mon nom et christina maria
malouf et j'ai des questions à vous
poser donc en regardant les nouvelles
qui ici est déjà tombé sur des articles
sur la crypto monnaie combien d'entre
vous ont déjà fait des articles sur la
corée du nord
comment penseriez-vous par dessus un
tizi nombre à bhl tweet vie revenant de
ce charmant bonhomme est ce que c'est
vraiment tout ce qui se passe sur notre
planète de près de sept milliards
d'habitants en vous demandant si vous
avez déjà entendu parler du génocide au
myanmar au lieu des mails vais je
m'attendrais plutôt à un attend quoi
un génocide un mac elle fait que ce soit
un génocide
premièrement donc c'est un événement
assez imposant et deuxièmement ça s'est
passé l'an dernier
donc c'est quand même assez d'actualité
je m'intéresse vraiment aux raisons pour
lesquelles certaines nouvelles passent
inaperçus donc 59 pour cent des
canadiens disent que le web et plus
particulièrement les réseaux sociaux
sont leur première source de nouvelles
le web réuni environ 4 milliards de
personnes se donnent donc illusion que
ce que l'on y voie est représentatif de
la planète entière
par contre vous avez réalisé que ce que
vous lisez n'est pas tout ce qui se
passe sur la planète
pourquoi c'est à cause des algorithmes
non ne vous inquiétez pas vous avez pas
besoin d'être un spécialiste la
programmation pour savoir c'est quoi un
algorithme dans notre cas ici c'est une
suite d'opérations mathématique qui
permet d'optimiser les résultats d'une
recherche les sites web utilisent les
algorithmes ainsi que 56 autres facteurs
pour vous suggérer les nouvelles des
[ __ ] ayé personnel personnellement pour
vous oui ça permet une expérience de
navigation beaucoup plus personnalisé
est beaucoup plus agréable mais de notre
bord salim est notre ouverture d'esprit
et notre connaissance des événements
mondiaux donc ces facteurs peuvent être
votre ange votre
votre localisation la position physique
dans laquelle vous êtes donc si vous
êtes debout ou assis et oui votre
appareil le sait pour publication penser
que vous avez consulté vos réactions ces
publications penser que vous avez
consulté les publications que vos amis
ont consulté et ses rangs et c'est donc
la façon que ça fonctionne c'est que
vous commencez par cliquer sur
l'arctique qui vous intéressent ensuite
vos préférences sont sauvegardés envie
de vous suggérer des articles dans le
futur à la longue vous finissez toujours
pas être exposés aux mêmes types
d'informations ce qui limite l'ouverture
d'esprit le problème avec ça c'est que
vous ne sortez jamais de votre zone de
confort tout ce que vous voyez des
renforcer les idées que vous aviez déjà
vos opinions que vous avez déjà ça va à
l'encontre de l'égalité sociale ça va à
l'encontre la justice ça va à l'encontre
des valeurs de la génération z
c'est comme voir le monde à travers une
paille
les algorithmes fonctionne tellement
bien que certaines informations ne
pourront jamais nous parvenir c'est
d'être assez informés n'est ce pas quand
on ne sait pas ce qu'on nous cache bien
que j'ai dit bien que j'aie démoniser
les algorithmes dans cette partie de la
présentation
il représente en fait une solution au
problème mais avant de continuer
pourquoi est ce que c'est si important
de rester informés pourquoi est-ce que
je met tant d'emphase là dessus c'est
parce que des événements tragiques passe
inaperçu comme les initiés dont j'ai
parlé avant comme les catastrophes
naturelles au sierra leone où la
population a désespérément besoin d'un
de l'aide humanitaire ihh l'appui du
public
votre appui révolution des situations
prenez par exemple précise mon haïti en
2010 la population du monde s'est rallié
pour envoyer de l'argent de l'aide
humanitaire et des dons matériels aux
pays en détresse avec les contributions
de chacun
il ya une grande différence tout ça pour
vous dire que prendre conscience de la
situation représente le début de son
changement
nous avons le pouvoir de devenir plus
informés et ce plus que jamais
aujourd'hui du butoh doigts est ce que
ça veut dire qu'il faut mener cette
bataille seul
bien sûr que non les développeurs web
pourrait modifier les algorithmes afin
de nous suggérer des parts égales
puisque l'utilisateur m déjà et une part
complètement différente
en se basant sur l'historique de
navigation qui est déjà récolté toutes
manières par exemple à une personne qui
lit beaucoup d'articles sur les
terroristes au moyen orient
il reste seulement une mauvaise
perspective des gens qui vivent là bas
mais par contre l'algorithme viendrait
suggérer des articles sur les chefs
d'entreprise en jordanie qui viennent
aider les réfugiés syriens à se bâtir
une nouvelle vie au pays
ça change les perspectives ça change les
stéréotypes intel algorithmes
suggéraient des nouvelles venant de tous
les continents
quand on entend le plus possible tous
les sujets par contre les algues vertes
ne vont probablement peu changé tito est
ce que c'est une excuse pour vous
asseoir et vous tourner les pouces
bien sûr que non allez par vous même sur
un site différent
ayé une curiosité insatiable études il
aborde de recherche à votre avantage
c'est pas juste une décoration sortez de
votre zone de confort et ne laissez pas
les autres
les algorithmes vous fermez les yeux
passé comme le dirait gandhi soyez le
changement que vous désirez voir dans ce
monde
merci